ils sont prêts comme toujours les scouts
de france ont planté leur tente à jour
ville dans les yvelines pour leur 2e
jean bourrât nationale qui se déroule
jusqu'à lundi
cette rencontre de la camaraderie et de
la débrouillardise doit réunir quelques
dix huit mille jeunes guillaume à perte
de vue
mais vous le cacher c'est une décharge
et d'odeurs et verre colliers et oui le
scoutisme malgré ses 70 ans d'âge sait
s'adapter même à la mode du rap une
adaptation qui lui réussit puisque cette
troupe de colmar va rejoindre quelques
18000 scout pour leur deuxième jambe
aurait pourtant le port du chapeau à
quatre bosses et les surnoms d'animaux
ont encore la vie dure
l'esprit du scoutisme lui n'a pas changé
le fameux feu de camp les chansons ne
sont pas près de s'éteindre et la
franche camaraderie règne toujours
qu'est ce qui te plaît dans le scoutisme
balle et gelé les marches les vélos être
comme ça ça nous apprend à nous
débrouiller fait plein de choses et puis
c'est marc os et lesbiens les 40 scouts
de colmar répète une dernière fois leur
prestation de dimanche au jamboree avec
quelques petits problèmes de
synchronisation
mais au fait les chansons léveillé n'est
ce pas un peu démodé non je ne pense pas
je pense que une veillée bien fait c'est
une veillée où on raconte vraiment qui
on est une vidéo où chacun participe
salariale dépasser le scout vie la
nature l'avait y est une façon de
s'exprimer avec les moyens qu'on a des
moyens limités le feu en état
alors qu'on se dise les scouts évolué
mais resteront toujours les scouts
tant pis pour ceux qui n'aiment ni la
nature ni les chemises bleues ni la
guitare et qui ne sont jamais prêt